المترجم: Ruba Kal Omar
المدقّق: Hanan Ben Nafa
لقد ولدت ونشأت في ولاية الجزيرة.
درست المرحلة الابتدائيّة
إلى أن وصلت للصف السابع في مدني.
لقد كنت شديدة التعلّق بمدني.
بسبب وجود كل أهلي وصديقاتي فيها.
صدر قراراً في عام 2006 وفي بموجبه
نقل والدي لمدينة "الأُبيض".
كان القرار صادماً جدّاً بالنسبة لي،
لم أستطع تقبّله أو التعايش معه.
لكن لم يكن هناك حلّ سوى السفر.
وصلنا إلى الأُبيض.
لم أكن مسرورة أبداً.
كنت دائماً ما أجري
مقارنات بين مدني وأُبيض.
كان مرور الأيام عليّ ثقيلاً.
انتهت الإجازة، وتم تسجيلي في مدرسة الدوحة،
وبدأت الصف الثامن.
في الدوحة، يمكنني القول
إنني تقبلت الفكرة.
ولكنني لم أكن متأقلمةً تماماً.
قمت بامتحان الشهادة الأساسيّة،
وتم قبولي بعدها في مدرسة
السيّد علي المرغني.
(تصفيق)
وكانت هذه هي نقطة التحول في حياتي.
كانت هذه بداية اكتشافي لذاتي.
في السيد علي المرغني، وجدت نفسي.
اكتشفت ذاتي.
وعرفت من هي آمنة،
وما عندها وما يمكنها تقديمه.
لذلك، ومنذ اليوم الأول في هذه المدرسة،
لم أشعر بالوحدة.
أولاً، كل زميلاتي اللواتي كُنَّ معي في الدوحة،
تم قبولهن معي في ذات المدرسة.
وتم تعيين عدد كبير منهنّ معي في فصل واحد.
منذ اليوم الأول في المدرسة، كان دخول
المعلمين والمعلمات يعطينا إحساساً بالاطمئنان.
وكذلك تعامل الخالات والعاملين.
كان كل شيء يعطيك إحساساً بأنّ أيامك القادمة
ستكون أجمل في هذه المدرسة.
وفعلاً، الحمد للّه، كانت هذه الأيام
وما زالت وستظل الأحلى.
فكلّما مرت الأيام، يزيد تعلّقي
بالمدرسة وبمعلماتي.
وأحبهم أكثر،
وأدى ذلك إلى جعلي أحب الأُبيض.
الأُبيض التي كنت أكرهها من قبل،
ولم أكن أتقبل فكرة قدومي لها،
أصبحت أحبّها، وأشعر بالانتماء لها.
أصبحت عندما أعود لمدني في العطلة،
أنتظر انتهاءها لكي تتسنى لي العودة للأُبيض.
(تصفيق)
انتهيت من السنة الأولى،
وبدأت السنة الثانية،
حصلت معي في السنة الثانية أشياء جميلة جداّ،
وأنا سعيدة بها.
وأتحدّث عنها دائماً.
وسأبقى فخورة بها.
الشيء الأول هو اختياري كطالبة مثالية
على مستوى الولاية.
(تصفيق)
الشيء الثاني هو مشاركتي في الدورة المدرسية
القوميّة في غونغولا في المطارحة الشعريّة،
وفوزي بالميدالية البرونزية.
(تصفيق)
استفدت أشياء كثيرة.
قابلت أناساً من ولايات مختلفة.
عرفت وتعلّمت العديد من الأشياء الجديدة
خلال الخمسة عشر يوماً التي قضيتها هناك.
فكان هذان الشيئان كفيلَين بأن يزيدا حبّي
لمدرسة السيد علي المرغني،
وأن يزيدا حبي لمعلماتي،
وأن يجعلاني مسرورة،
لأنني كنت قد اكتشفت للتوّ ما أملك،
وما أستطيع تقديمه.
فاكتشاف ذاتي كان هنا.
أحببت المدرسة جدّاً.
وفي الجلسات، أنا دائمة التحدث
عن معلّماتي وعن مدرستي.
بدأت السنة الثالثة.
كانت صديقاتي وبنات خالتي يقلن لي:
"ألا تملكين حديثاً آخراً غير المدرسة وما قالته معلماتك؟
سوف ينسينك بالتأكيد عندما تتركين المدرسة،
وبالكاد سيتذكرن اسمك".
كنت أجيبهن: "لا، لن يحدث هذا".
وقد حصلت أشياء أثبتت لي هذا.
في الصف الثالث الثانوي،
ومنذ بدء الامتحانات،
وقع لي حادث مؤلم.
تعرض والدي لحادث
في فترة امتحاناتي،
كنت فاقدة للسّند.
لم يكن أبي أو أمي بجانبي.
لكن معلّماتي كنّ هنّ سندي.
(تصفيق)
كانوا دائماً يسألون عنّا.
ويتفقّدون أحوالي وأحوال أختي في المدرسة.
فشعرت بأن لديّ أناساً يدعمونني.
ويفكرون في همومي وهموم أهل بيتي.
وهذا شيء أخر زاد من حبي وتعلّقي بهم.
انتهت السنة الثالثة،
وبدأت مشواري في الجامعة.
وذلك الكلام عن أن معلماتي سينسينني
ولن يتذكرن اسمي، لم يحدث.
(تصفيق)
أبسط مثال على هذا
أمّي الأستاذة نازك مرغنة،
كما أحبّ أن أناديها،
(تصفيق)
كانت تتذكر عيد ميلادي في كل مرّة.
وترسل لي التهاني،
قد ترونه شيئاً بسيطاً،
لكنه شيء كبير بالنسبة لي،
ترك في داخلي أثراً عميقاً،
ووضّح لي مدى اهتمامها
بأدّق تفاصيلي،
وهي متواجدة الليلة بين الحضور لدعمي،
(تصفيق)
كانت معلماتي حاضرات في
كل تفاصيل حياتي.
ناقشت بحث التخرج،
وأول من عرف بهذا معلماتي،
وقد أرسلت لهم رسائل شكر،
"شكراً لكم، فلولاكم لم أكن لأصل
لهذا المكان،
وأدعو الله أن يجزيكم عني خير الجزاء"،
أرسل التهاني لكل معلّماتي في عيد الأم،
لأنهن في مقام أمهاتنا،
ولا أحد يستطيع إنكار هذا،
فهنّ كُن حاضرات معي في كل شيء.
ولم أغب عنهن ولم يغبن عني.
عندما دخلت إلى الجامعة،
كنت أفكر بتقديم هديّة ما لمعلماتي،
كي أسعدهن وأُدخل الفرحة إلى قلوبهن، وأريهن
مدى تقدري لما فعلنه من أجلي،
ليس فقط من أجلي، بل من أجل الجميع،
لكنه كان إحساساً في داخلي أنا.
لذلك فكرت في خمسة أشياء،
أو بالأحرى قمت بخمسة أشياء،
أولاً، أول فكرة خطرت في بالي
وألهمني الله إياها
هي أن أكفل يتيماً باسم كل
معلم ومعلّمة قاموا بتدريسي،
لذلك اشتركت في منظمة كفالة اليتيم،
فكنت أدّخر جزءاً معيناً من مصروفي الشهري،
وأخصصه لكفالة اليتيم،
كنت أحدّد مبلغاً - قد يكون بسيطاً -
لكل معلّم ومعلّمة
لكنه يساوي كثيراً عند الله،
"ومن يعمل مثقال ذرّة خيراً يره"
وأسأل ربّنا القبول،
لم أكن أحب التحدّث في هذا الأمر،
أو لم أكن أتخيل أنني سأتحدّث
في هذا الأمر في يوم من الأيام،
ولم يكن أحد على علم بهذا
غيري أنا وأمي نازك،
لكنني أتيت الليلة وتحدّثت بها
لعلّ وعسى أحد ما منكم يستفيد من الأمر،
لعلّ وعسى أحد ما منكم يتخذها وسيلةً
كي يتعامل بها مع من يحب ومع أولئك القريبين منه،
لأني لم أكن لأحصل على شيء كهذا إن
لم يكن لمعلمي ومعلماتي الدور الأكبر فيه، ولكن...
(تصفيق)
واحدة من الأشياء التي أقوم بها أيضاً
حتى الآن وحتى آخر يوم في حياتي،
ولن تنقطع أبداً بإذن الله،
الدّعاء،
ليس هناك أجمل من أن تدعي لمن تحب
بظهر الغيب،
فالحمد لله،
لم يمر يوم عليّ، إلا ودعيت فيه
لكل معلم ومعلّمة قاموا بتدريسي
من مرحلة الروضة وحتى الجامعة،
أن يجزيهم ربّي عنّي خير الجزاء،
وأن يهيّئ لي الله الفرصة كي أردّ لهم الدَّين،
أو أن أتمكن من فعل شيءٍ ولو بسيطٍ
من أجلهم،
لذلك فإن الدعاء أيضاً هو شيء
أريدكم أن...
من يقم بهذا الأمر ... جيد،
ومن لا يقوم به فأنا أوجه له رسالة
أن يبدأ منذ الليلة بالتعامل بالدعاء
مع أحبته والأُناس القريبين منه،
عندما وصلت إلى الجامعة،
في آخر سنتين أو آخر سنة،
حضرت فعالية جميلة جداً قامت بها
منظمة صناع الحياة،
مبادرة اسمها أسبوع المعلّم،
يُكَرّم فيها المعلمون، فهم يستحقون التكريم،
سألت نفسي: "لم لا أجلب هذه المبادرة للأٌيبض،
وأقيم أسبوع المعلم فيها،
طالما أنني أريد القيام بشيء يُسعد
المعلمين والمعلمات!"
فتمت إقامة أسبوع المعلم الأول في الأُبيض.
(تصفيق)
قدمت من الخرطوم،
واجتهدت أن أجد الدعم،
اجتهدت في تدريب فتيات،
اجتهدت في تجهيز برنامج،
وأقمت أسبوع المعلم،
وقد تألف البرنامج من يومين،
فنسبة لظروف كثيرة، لم يكن أسبوعاً كاملاً.
كان مدته يومين فقط،
وقد كانا أجمل يومين،
أُقيم اليوم الأول في مدرسة الدوحة الخاصة،
لأنني درست فيها خلال السنة الثامنة،
فكرّمت فيها جميع المعلّمين والمعلّمات،
القدماء والجدد،
وقد كان هناك لمسة وفاءٍ في البرنامج،
وكانت اللمسة هي عمل صدقة جارية على
روح الأستاذ عثمان الباغر رحمه الله.
(تصفيق)
وقد توفقت في هذا الأمر ولله الحمد،
استطعت القيام بسبيلٍ في مدرسة
مصعب بن عمير في الوحدة،
فهذه هي المنطقة التي تواجد بها،
وبيته إلى الآن فيها،
وزوجته أيضاً في هذه المدرسة،
فقمت بهذا الأمر،
رأيت سعادة المعلمين به،
وقد كان تغييراً لهم وللطلبة،
لأن الوضع كان يسوده بعض التوتر بسبب الامتحانات،
حيث أنهم لم يحضروا برامج مماثلة من قبل،
الكل كان سعيداً،
اليوم الثاني كان في مدرسة
السيد علي المرغني
وتم فيه أيضاً تكريم
جميع المعلمين والمعلمات،
القدماء والجدد،
رأيت الفرحة في عيونهم،
سمعت كلمات الفرح منهم،
فقد شعروا بأن هناك ولو واحدةً
من طالباتهم مقدرةٌ عملهم،
ولو واحدةً من طالباتهم
لا زالت تتذكر ما قاموا به من أجلها،
فقد كان هذا أجمل شيء بالنسبة لي،
ولم أكن أريد أكثر من ذلك،
والحمد لله، تم ذلك،
لمسة الوفاء في مدرسة السيد علي المرغني
كان من المقرر أن تكون عبارة عن صيانة
لحوض مدرسة سمية بنت الخياط في البترون،
على روح الأستاذ أسمر بن رحيم،
رحمه الله وجعله من أصحاب اليمين،
لم يتم هذا الأمر،
لكنه سيتم إن شاء الله في
الأسبوع الثاني للمعلم في الأُبيض،
من حبي لمدرسة السيد علي المرغني،
كنت دائماً أسعى بأية طريقة
لرفع اسم المدرسة والإضافة له،
وقد سمعت عن مسابقة تحدّي القراءة بالعربي،
فإذاً لم لا تشارك مدرستي فيها؟
ولم لا يكون لمدرستي حضور في هذه المسابقة؟
فقمت بتسجيل المدرسة،
وتسجيل الطالبات،
وقمنا بمتابعتهم أنا وأمي الأستاذة
نازك مرغني،
وشاركنا،
وحصلنا على المرتبة التاسعة على مستوى
السودان في مسابقة تحدي القراءة العربي
(تصفيق)
سلمى عبد الباقي أحمد
ستسافر في الخامس عشر من أكتوبر
من أجل حضور المنافسات النهائية في دبي،
فكان هذا شيء رفع من مكانة المدرسة،
(تصفيق)
الشيء الخامس الذي قمت به من أجل
من أجل معلماتي ومعلمي ومدرستي،
الشيء الأخير هو إنشاء مبادرة أو منظمة
خريجات مدرسة السيد علي المرغني،
(تصفيق)
وتم تسجيلها قبل البارحة
الحمد لله
وسيكون لنا بعون الله وجوداً في الأُبيّض،
وفي أي مجال تطوعي أو خيري،
وسيكون لنا شاء الله بصمة واضحة في
تحسين البيئة التعليمية،
ولو قدّر لنا الله ذلك، مع أن الأمر كبير،
سنقوم بتحسين أوضاع المعلمين،
لأن المعلم يستحق،
ولولا المعلم...
(تصفيق)
لما استطاع أحد منا الوصول
إلى ما وصلنا له اليوم،
المعلمون في بلدنا متعبون جداً،
لكن بالرغم من تعبهم،
وكل ما يتحمّلونه،
يأتون المدرسة،
ويضعون كل هذا وراء ظهورهم،
في سبيل إيصال رسالتهم على أكمل وجه،
في سبيل ألا يقصّروا،
في سبيل إنشاء جيل مثقفٍ، وواعٍ، ومدرك،
ينسون كل أشياءهم ويرمون جميع أحزانهم،
ومن ضمن أحد الأشياء الأخرى التي أثرت في:
في أحد الأيام في مدرسة السيّد علي المرغني
أردت دخول درس اللغة الإنجليزية
مع أمي نازك،
أحسست بأن شيئاً ما قد تغيّر فيها،
سألتها: ما بك؟
عرفت أنها قد قدمت لتوها من عزاء قريبتها،
فكان الحزن ظاهراً،
يمكن ألا يكون هذا ظاهراً لشخص آخر،
ولكنني قريبة منها،
وأرى الحزن ظاهر على وجهها،
لكن لديها صفاً دراسياً،
لم تعتذر،
ولم تقل "لا، لن أدخل"،
أو "لدي عذر يمنعني من إلقاء الدرس"،
لقد دخلت معها وتفاجأت
أنها كانت تعطينا أمثلة،
وكانت تبتسم وتضحك مع الفتيات،
وكانت تعطيهم أمثلة تساعدهم على الفهم،
فقد رمت كل شيء وراءها،
من أجل تأدية رسالتها،
رمت كل شيء وراءها
كي لا تقصّر في شيء،
وليس هذا حالها هي فقط،
بل هو حال كل معلم ومعلمة في السودان،
مؤلم جداً، مؤلم جداً،
فبعد كل ما يقوم به المعلمون والمعلمات،
نجد طالباً لا يحترمهم،
نجد طالباً لا يقدّرهم،
فهذه دعوة مني لكم جميعكم،
أن نفكر ونجلس مع أنفسنا قليلاً،
ونتفكر في ما يقدمونه لنا،
وكيف يمكن أن نحسّن أوضاع المعلمين،
وكيف نرد لهم الجميل،
ولو بكلمة، كلمة شكر،
أن تقول لمعلمك:
"شكراً، أتمنى من الله أن يجزيك
عني خير الجزاء،
أقدر ما تقوم به من أجلي"،
إن أخطأت تعتذر منهم،
فهذه دعوة أن نراجع أنفسنا جميعاً،
وأن ننظر بعيون أخرى للمعلم،
وأن نغير من نظرتنا تجاهه،
لأنهم فعلاً يستحقون كل التقدير،
ومن هنا،
هذه دعوة لكم جميعاً،
أن تكونوا حضوراً معنا في أسبوع المعلم القادم،
من الحادي عشر وحتى الثامن عشر من نوفمبر،
في مدينة الأُبيّض، إن شاء الله.
أياً كانت الطريقة التي تود دعمنا بها،
بأي طريقة تستطيع التواجد معنا من خلالها
ودعمنا عن طريقها،
فأنت مرحّب بك،
كي نتحد جميعاً وننتج شيئاً جميلاً،
كي نقول للأساتذة:
"لم ننسَ فضلكم علينا"،
"لم ننسَ ما قدمتموه لنا"،
يا قوم ردّوا للمعلّم حقّه
فرضاً له في عنقكم ولزاماً
فالله لا يهب النجاة لموطنٍ
تلقى المعلم في حماه مضاماً
(تصفيق)
تطوير وتطور الأمم
يبدأ بالتعليم،
والتعليم نبدأ بالمعلم،
ومن أجل هذا،
من أجل ما وجدته في المعلمين والمعلمات،
أودّ ولو لفترة قصيرة
الدخول في مجال التعليم،
كي أصبح معلمة،
كي أستطيع تقديم ما قدمه لي أساتذتي
لطلاب وطالبات آخرين،
كي أستطيع أن أقدم لهم شيئاً
ما يشعرهم بما أشعر به تجاه المعلمين،
أنا متأكدة أنه لو حصل هذا الأمر،
سوف يكون هناك اختلافاً كبيراً
في نظرتنا للمعلم،
في تقديرنا للمعلم،
لذلك أتمنى من الله أن يجزي كل معلم ومعلمة
قاموا بتدريسي
وجميع المعلمين في شتّى بقاع الأرض،
ربنا يجزيهم عنا خير الجزاء،
وشكراً.